well which of your favorite stores could
be closing this year
as a result of the pandemic so far we've
already seen several popular
chains like steinmart and pier one
imports liquidated
but others fared pretty well places like
target
walmart and dick's sporting goods
kirsten joyce joining us now with
the outlook for retail kirsten denise
moody's investor service which studies
the realtors
sector says department stores specialty
and apparel store suffered the most
during 2020.
the industry's strongly retailers are
hoping that a nationwide vaccination
campaign
will bring them back from the brink but
when you have restrictions that continue
like in california and other states that
limit the number of shoppers who can
enter their stores well that certainly
makes an impact
15 jc penney stores will be closing in
mid-march but not any in our state
neiman marcus one of the first major
realtors to file for bankruptcy
protection during the pandemic is also
on moody's list of vulnerable retailers
as is tuesday morning christopher and
banks joanne stores party city and rite
aid
now macy's announced in february it
planned to cut 2 000
jobs and close one-fifth of its stores
roughly 125 locations over the next few
years
it will not be closing any in our state
it appears to be in better shape than
some of its competitors finishing out
the year
strong and as far as bed bath and beyond
is concerned
it is planning to close some 200 stores
by the end of this year
but no locations in nevada